Westworld season 2 episode 3 begins in a
new park called the raj just like West
world is based on the American Wild West
and Shogun world on feudal Japan the raj
is based on the raj period in india when
it was ruled by the british empire so we
see hookers and rickshaws and peacocks
and elephants and someone plays a sitar
but the song is seven nation army
because why let historical accuracy get
in the way of her banger the guests
Grace and Nicholas hook up but grey
suspects that Nick might be a host and
she doesn't want to [ __ ] a robot because
robots aren't free they just do as
they're told but Nick says doing what
you're told can be half the fun he likes
being controlled so even this random sex
scene raises questions about freedom and
control which is what this shows all
about to make sure Nick is human grace
shoots him because the high-tech bullets
in West world are coded to only hurt
hosts at least they were until Dolores's
rebellion when Ford reprograms the guns
to kill humans as well which means that
these Raj scenes are a flashback
happening sometime in season 1 Grace and
Nick go on a tiger hunt but grace is
hunting for something else she has a map
with this hexagonal pattern which also
appears around Dallas as secret data
project so is Grace Adela's employee
helping them secure their data or does
she have her own plans the hosts in the
Raj go rogue and start killing guests so
this bit probably happens around the
same time that the West world hosts
rebel Grace escapes then gets chased by
a tiger the same animal they were
hunting across the parks the humans have
become the hunted the tiger knocks grace
off a cliff and they wash up in West
world where Tiger dies and becomes the
same Tiger we see in episode 1 then
grace meets some hosts of ghost nation
who have secrets of their own we jump to
the two weeks ahead timeline with
Bernard strand security and Charlotte
Marling mentions that someone took out
of the cradle according to a West World
email the cradle is a simulation
technology that stores and tests spark
storylines online the cradle appears as
a ready you shaped room which looks like
this room in
trailer the cradle might connect to
Dallas's secret project of recording
guests behavior because that behavior
data might help with simulating behavior
in the cradle and maybe if you could
perfectly simulate people you could make
copies of people as robots like in the
future world movie this could explain
this shot in an alternate trailer which
seems to show old William with James
Delos James was sick and dying thirty
years ago so how is he alive in the
present
maybe this James is actually a robot
clone of the original made with data in
the cradle but why would someone take
out the cradle maybe for the same reason
someone flooded this valley where the
daughter project seems to be William
described this place as his greatest
mistake
maybe he destroys it Bernard flashes
back awake to the present timeline where
he and Charlotte search for Peeta
Abernathy because Peter has secret day
loss daughter in his head they find
Peter with the host rebus who's selling
people as slaves to the Confederate OHS
we don't know if rebus is programmed to
do this know if he's choosing to do it
because he's just immoral but then
Bernard reprograms rebuses personality
to make him a virtuous good guy which
explains why a week later in Episode one
rebus tries to protect another host when
the Confederate OHS arrive rebus fights
to protect his former slaves is rebus
acting freely here he says he's heeding
his convictions but Bernard just changed
rebuses convictions
this could even if we are free were
bound to follow our personalities and
values in the chaos Charlotte escapes
but Bernard and Peter are captured
Dolores takes over the Confederate o
army promising to help them beat the
humans and get to glory which is the
flooded Valley weapon data place Dolores
has Clementine is acting like a murder
zombie since she got lobotomized last
season Clementine was built to be killed
without mercy
now she kills without mercy Peter
arrives and has an emotional reunion
with Dolores because he was her host
father back at the ranch
but Peters brain is scrambled ever since
Charlotte and Lee filled it with del
estado last season
Charlotte tried to smuggle Peter out of
the park on a train which is why he
keeps saying I need to get to the train
his mind keeps bouncing between old
personalities so sometimes he speaks
like Dolores his father but sometimes he
speaks like the professor an old role he
played who liked to quote Shakespeare so
pate recites lines from King Lear
Dolores feels conflicted because she
wants to reject her old fake life and
wage a war against humans she tells the
Confederate OHS to call her Wyatt the
bad guy role but Dolores still loves the
men she was programmed to love Peter and
Teddy so kind of like Peter Dolores is
torn between different identities maybe
that means she's a malfunctioning
machine or maybe being truly conscious
and human means juggling different
identities and roles while Dolores shows
love for Peter she's harsh to Bernard
tossing him in jail maybe she's mad that
he was her jailer in Westworld for all
those years but at the same time she
recognizes Bernard as the replacement of
Arnold Dolores is creator who she saw as
a sort of a father so she wants Bernard
to approve of her plan to dominate the
world but Bernard is not so sure about
her war
Bernard looks at the Dada in Peters head
and is shocked though we only see this
hexagonal symbol from the Delos Dada
project and graces notebook Dolores
fights a battle against Delos security
who decide that their best tactical
option is to slowly walk across a field
two words the deathbots
Dolores blows up the humans but she also
betrays and kills that Confederate Oz
why does Dolores kill other hosts she
tells them the same thing that she tells
a ghost nation hosts in episode one
though we don't all deserve to make it
to the valley beyond Dolores judges the
Confederate owes unworthy and they do
seem like pricks but they were
programmed that way right we just saw
how rebus can be switched from a villain
to a hero so can you really judge a
machine for following its code maybe
Dolores blames the hosts for not
awakening to full consciousness like she
did but it took too
Laura's decades of wandering the maze to
awake so is it really fair to blame
these guys Dolores
tells Teddy to execute the Confederated
survivors but he disobeys and lets them
go
Teddy is finally thinking for himself
but how will Dolores react also during
the battle Charlotte takes Peter but we
know from the week ahead timeline that
she later loses him again and Charlotte
seems to suspect that Bernard is
responsible mave Hector and Lea are on
their way to find Maeve's daughter when
they encounter some hosts of ghost
nation may have recognized as one hosts
who attacked her in her past life at the
homestead the hosts demand that Maeve
give them Lea Maeve refuses and tries to
use her power to control them but they
resist her command
so maven code run away why are these
hosts immune to Maeve's Jedi Mind Tricks
she's commanded Bernard a sheriff Li's
cannibal what makes these ghost nation
hosts different and why do they want lis
but not Maeve or Hector
is it because lis is human they did
capture Stubbs last season and now
apparently grace it looks like ghost
nation is collecting humans but why some
fans theorize that they're trying to
protect humans possibly they're working
with Elsie one way or another ghost
nation will be a big part of this season
especially with the character a catch
eater who also appears in Maeve's
flashback Sizemore gets mad about Maeve
and Hector's relationship he wrote these
characters and he's upset to see them
change off his script like an author who
doesn't like fan fiction Hector says
that his old scripted love was fake but
his new love with Maeve is real but then
Lee shows that Hector uses scripted
dialogue to describe his new love so
does this mean that Hector's love isn't
real or is he just using the words he
knows to express something true maybe
all of us are limited by our language
and culture
it's our programming Maeve meets up with
Armistice Felix and Sylvester Armistice
has a new arm because she lost her old
one last season the party passes through
a snowy area which might suggest the
delos can control the weather and they
encounter a warrior from Shogun world we
don't know if this guy came across too
West world from Shogun world or if Lee's
directions are so bad that they
accidentally wandered into Shogun world
or maybe Lee deliberately misled them
however it happened this culture clash
may complicate Maeve's quest so this
episode focuses closely on the central
questions of West world like what is
freedom and how do our desires and
personalities and identities affect that
can you morally judge a machine what
does love mean to a machine and what
kind of black mirror blade runner'
shenanigans can we achieve with big data
and robotics West world is trying to ask
some really big questions for more West
world analysis check out the subreddit
and the podcasts decoding West world
bold move and others thank you to the
patrons for supporting alt shift X
including Marisa shacket Cain O'Banion
Yami Judy Cooper peloton and sock C&O
Cheers
you